[Music]
in ghost virus news wood submitted by
hide yo kids hide your wife a town has
enforced a curfew to protect young
people from evil spirits oh thank god
finally I love this the freaks come out
at night yeah this is like oh why did
why did why was that person drunk
Driving's like was it a spirit that my
mom should tell me that the evil spirits
come out after 9 p.m. and they like to
hide specifically behind the trees only
trees yeah so she was like not poles
nothing to help you out past 9:00 and if
you are out avoid trees oh if you wanna
feel you're good I guess so I didn't
live mostly I'll come back like when
they go back to I think it's probably
somewhere around sunrise yeah buck goes
during the day because that happens in
movies my back so this town is in
Columbia and so the mayor and bullets
are town named Pajarito is the name of
the town so how deep oh yeah it's in
northern Colombia so the mayor has now
announced a curfew forbidding the
transit or gathering of minors under the
age of 17 in public places between 7:00
p.m. and 5:00 a.m.
oh so there's this like thing happening
with whatsapp there's been at least 14
cases of teenagers that are just acting
really strange and they're threatening
to kill themselves by jumping off
bridges or like cutting themselves and
that they're fainting and that they have
unexplained changes in their voices and
there's like going through puberty
that's what that [ __ ] that calls up
their emotional wreck voices are
cracking we don't know what to do
they touch the dick why did I keep
so they say that the common thing
between all these teenagers is that
they're using whatsapp so obviously
they're getting these these girls they
don't listen to what's going on in their
house or in their lives
it's do what they concluded it was ooh
what's up yeah they take no
accountability for how they raise your
kid I've never seen it before never seen
it I've never been on whatever is either
for real yeah I'll show you it's just an
app yes like a messaging app like group
me yeah but what's the app whatsapp yeah
looks like this so you have it yeah I
don't know you talk to the public or you
just talk to your friends no just your
friends just or like whoever you add to
that specific group yeah just like a
group child but you don't get all these
creases just D yes yeah I've literally
never seen that so okay no you literally
just saw it it was green one was that
okay yeah who's mark this is the
scandalous one he says thanks and then
he used an emoji that I wouldn't use
unless well in that way I said happy
birthday for your wife what do you use
for your wife I use pretty scandalous a
thumbs up I don't know actually
thumbs up because she knows where the
thumbs going where is it going cuz I
don't know oh it's going somewhere okay
yeah it's going in my but it's for me
one thumb and the button one mouth
electric current between the two mm-hmm
that's cool yeah so this mayor here so
he's saying like you made this decision
based on the red alert cases that happen
I can't believe it I love their [ __ ]
detective skills so from 7 p.m. mm-hm
and they can't use whatsapp then they
didn't even mention that they're just
saying that they've all been using
what's that did they hire like priests
or something or less the whole time
saying that they that he consulted with
the local police legalistic illegal
existence of the mayor's office and
psychologists and so he decided that the
best way to stop children from doing
anything crazy under the influence of
these evil spirits was to enforce a
curfew keep them at home but that's
funny cuz he like uncovered this mystery
that it's all because of whatsapp and
he's not one thing was talked about and
they're also saying that parents whose
children are caught breaking the curfew
will receive hefty fine I've been
reading that exorcisms are right now at
an all-time high did an article where
they're like they're hiring the church
is hiring more priests because they need
more exorcisms yeah they need to do
exercise I'm on their actual priest I
know right that's true there's that
scandal - oh yeah the priests must be
touching kids and stuff that's never
gone away for 50 years yeah yeah no just
watch the movie we have to get divorced
if that happens I heard someone we
witness an exorcism
yes what if you bring some weird shits
will you believe that they will jump
from that body into yours I'm gonna
bring that monster to believe in what
you told me this told you guys you are
no longer her best friend your saw what
are your in one I didn't see one I
didn't I wasn't in one I heard one other
room how do you hear one oh you must
thorry
alright see she's all the way over there
and I'm like please alright so who's in
live in Mexico so I lived in myself for
one year when I was 15 people think I
was born there were no I wasn't anyway
so I was there and my family convinced
me to go to this thing called like the
theater so like a retreat and so retreat
in Spanish a retreat oh that's not
retreated sounds like a serial treat oh
yeah that girl right saying like it
wasn't a religious thing whatever but it
turns out it was anyway the point is
that we're out there for three days you
can't sleep the whole time on the second
day and they also make you like write
all I like the thing like you're just
like fleshing out everything that's bad
in your life that sounds like some
brainwashing tactic sleep deprivation
competitive [ __ ] and making you
vulnerable and write out your deepest
darkest secrets yeah and then I would
love to see you with the psychologist
you think so tell me what's going on
really
whoa this is some weird [ __ ] bro oh this
is like a cult after like you're right
you're spent you spent the entire night
writing right the first night and then
the second night you spend that whole
time talking to someone and reading to
them what you wrote and they're called
the ear like you know die cut and then
so there anyway so then that and then
during that time other you burn the [ __ ]
that you're right another cold Lodi
cousin set of alleles tell me about it
yeah cuz I guess cuz for Arnie - I don't
know that's interesting
so then years ago yep yeah so then like
at some point in that weekend they were
saying that this woman was having an
exorcism so there was like this mother
of two kids and she was there and like I
don't know what like she had she went
through some crazy [ __ ] early in her
life and then that she started like
having like [ __ ] weird-ass [ __ ]
happened to her body I didn't see any of
this this is what they were they were
still friends because you didn't witness
it I didn't witness it but I did um was
that a real exorcism if is on Catholic
priests I don't know
only works with the cat but I do
remember like there were all these
people that like run that thing and that
they just kept running to where she was
which there was like a wall and like a
hill covering where she was I couldn't
see anything but I could hear everything
that was happening in her voice sounded
like a demon oh I wanna [ __ ] see this
[ __ ] people running in and also make 540
feet back to Ben
you almost got conned I think I did not
for sure this whole system to me sounds
like an orchestrated plan to get
everybody into becoming true believers
scare the [ __ ] out of them and then have
them lifelong payers of the church I
don't want to but it just sounded really
convincing yeah then after like they
took her off did you see any eyeballs
like over the wall at a time when no one
was in that Center cuz it was like this
there's some like Hacienda kind of place
where it was just like this big open
field and everyone was like behind the
wall of where we could see everything
because everyone was like in their own
little corners with the ears telling
them their whole life story and then so
it was during that time so no one would
actually witnessed it but everyone like
you know yeah yeah like meanwhile on the
other side of the wall they're like you
can they're like making this whole
production he's like hit the sheet with
the bat dude you're talking about a bet
during that same time so when I was out
like on the hill thing that's when they
made me have a bat and they made me like
hit this hill and like to get all my
aggression out I'm just like and they
wanted me to yell to like scream at the
top of your lungs get everything yeah
but now if we hand you a sledgehammer JK
party you've want to [ __ ] everything up
you found it and unlocked it but yeah it
was like spiritual pinata yeah but
they're just like it's not it's nothing
like religious or anything we're just
trying to like you're going to find
yourself it's funny how all religions
have the same kind of things where it's
like you're Catholic you got to go to
confessional if you're in Scientologist
you got to sit with somebody and tell
them all your [ __ ] [ __ ] on it exactly
same [ __ ] like what you went through
yeah sounds like in the forest or I'll
just like tell us all your deep darkest
[ __ ] so we're gonna be a thing they've
told me to so after you have these
retreats then like a week or two weeks
later you meet because they people come
from all over Mexico like all the
different cities to that one
and then so you go back to your hometown
and then you meet up with the people
that you went on the retreat that were
from your city so when I met up there
like you go up and you talked about how
the great theater experience was and
like how you are gonna recommend to
other people when all this [ __ ] and so
they were saying they were asking me
like don't you remember like you
remember don't you remember you said you
saw Jesus like you saw him and I'm like
what because during that time with the
whole bat thing they made me lay down I
mean they they were like visualize that
you're like you're going to the club
I'll tell me what do you see and I was
just like um I see this I guess I don't
know I was just making up some [ __ ] cuz
they just kept like trying to get some
[ __ ] out of me and then so they're
saying during that part that supposedly
I saw Jesus and I was saying like oh
he's so amazing and he's like guys in
your nose words
yeah they scare they were scamming you
for real that sounds like us cause I was
like I never said any of that but cool I
did awesome this is like I always wanted
to like for a cult
know what kind of I was do that virtual
video I always wanted to go to gay
conversion therapy oh yeah do that but
the whole time I'm just like it's like
what do you see on the inkblot and I'm
like Dix
anyway okay what about this and I'm like
big dicks exactly like what they think a
gay person would say I think I'm gay or
now I'm not cool and you try to kiss all
the guy yeah but I know how to get a
camera in there oh I can't wait til
technology gets so [ __ ] good to the
point where you could like wire some
[ __ ] yeah they have that today
no no like wire it to your skin oh yeah
that'll be next two classes are so
shitty because I've tried to [ __ ] with
those a couple of times and it like
basically has a [ __ ] GoPro like lens
right here in the middle you can see it
[ __ ] Budd with the three yeah you
might as well have a red light that
you're recording okay so bad
[Music]
[Music]